[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: Welcome
back to FinTech,
Shaping the World of Finance.
Today, we're going to
review developments
in finance and technology
related to capital markets.
And since there's so many
pieces with capital markets,
I've chosen to take the time
to dig more deeply into two
areas, online brokerage,
or really mobile brokerage
applications, and wealth
advising through robo advising.
But we'll touch upon the broader
capital markets as well as
a little touch on
cryptocurrencies
because some of the most
successful financial technology
companies in the capital
markets have actually
been crypto exchanges
and some of the endeavors
around crypto markets.
So if I just take a moment just
to share my screen and share
some slides, and
we'll get going here.
Online brokerage, this
is not a new tradition.
It goes back actually
several decades.
And so then the
question is, what's
happened here in the
last six or eight years?
What's happened that this
startup Robinhood and others
have really just toppled
over the last remaining
bits of the commission
structure that we've had?
Robo advising and
then capital markets,
FinTech startups more generally.
We'll have to do a quick
survey there and then
a little discussion
of what's happening
in crypto exchanges and
decentralized finance,
because it's really
the question,
will that actually
transform finance,
or will it stay as
it is right now,
a more narrow niche, though,
still a $200 billion asset
class environment?
But will some of
those technologies
come into mainstream finance?
So the readings
again were mostly
focused around those
two areas, robo advising
and online brokerage, and
how Robinhood has transformed
the industry, and how Charles
Schwab and others entered
into by the late part of 2019
what some call the New Broker
Wars, in part because of
this financial technology
along the way.
So just some lively questions
but a way to get us going here.
And hopefully somebody
wants to chime in.
How did online brokers
emerge during an earlier
FinTech development
period, during the '80s,
'90s, that sort of
internet technology,
FinTech technology area?
And then how Robinhood's
transformed maybe
this more recent era.
Romain, does anybody
want to dive in at all?
ROMAIN: Let's see.
Who will be the first
volunteer today?
GARY GENSLER: I mean,
everybody, we'll be talking
about this for the whole class.
But I just-- if anybody wants to
offer their thoughts to start.
ROMAIN: And we have Michael.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So when I think the
earlier FinTech startups,
I think just thinking
of edge of the internet.
I'm thinking like
PayPal, just ways
you can do online payments
and online interfaces for--
or sorry, not online brokers.
I'm thinking of E*TRADE, but
ways to make it without having
to call somebody on the phone.
I guess it was probably more
inaccessible when you actually
had to drive to the broker
directly or in-person.
Robinhood definitely
was more starting
to take the mobile-first
approach, started
tackling weaknesses of
the larger platforms,
such as user interface, make
it more accessible for somebody
to really just
trade from anywhere.
And then also the fee
structure was a huge part
of that, too, for trading.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
But I'm glad--
I'm actually glad
Michael raised PayPal,
because there's
analogies, and that's
what this class is really about.
It's finding what's happening
from a strategic point of view.
We're teaching finance,
technology, the intersection
but about the strategies.
And there's a lot of parallel.
There we were in the 1990s.
Some of it even started
a little earlier.
And online brokerage started--
E*TRADE, Ameritrade.
We'll dive into a number
of these companies
similar to PayPal
starting in 1998.
So I thank you, Michael,
for pulling that together--
PayPal starting in 1998.
That earlier wave, the
internet, access rather than
through bricks and mortar,
or physical checks,
or an old credit card
system vis-a-vis the payment
systems in PayPal, online
brokerage starts, emerges.
Does it take off?
Not entirely.
But over time, it's a big
story in the capital markets,
especially retail investing.
And then we get to
this other period,
a new form of technology,
largely about mobile phones,
but not entirely about
mobile phones also related
to open API and
access to the data.
Robinhood comes along.
And also in the
payment area-- we've
talked about this already
a few classes ago-- a lot
of these payment startups.
And Robinhood GEN really
further transforms an industry.
And by 2019, Robinhood had
almost as many members online
through their mobile app
with just a handful of years
as E*TRADE or many of
the brokerage firms.
So it's got that
parallels, and we're
going to dive into how
Robinhood pressed further.
And I'm wondering, Michael, do
you have a Robinhood account?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but I
haven't really used it
since I started paying loans.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, no.
I understand why you
might not be investing
while you're in school
and why you might not
have the money to do
it, but you actually
have a Robinhood account.
And while it's hard to
do it by a show of hands,
but I imagine that many
other students in the class
have downloaded the app.
So then a little
bit different area
that we're going to be chatting
about is robo advising.
How has that transformed the
provision of retail investment
management, and how is
big finance reacting?
And I'm wondering if, Romain,
if anybody wants to just take
a high level hit at that.
ROMAIN: I hope so.
We had great papers
on the topic.
Any volunteers?
Weiyi?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I guess from the robot
advisor perspective is sort of,
I personally feel, is a how
to transform people's behavior
from like now going to some
kind of financial advisors
to actually you're
now going through more
electronic platforms,
whereas traditionally,
especially for maybe the younger
generations were a lot more
used to doing things online.
I think robot advisors
provide them a new way
to construct their financial
portfolios rather than going
to a financial advisor.
So it's definitely feeling like
it's going to take a bite out
of the existing financial
advisors, which are probably
where we're talking about
from the retail asset manager
perspective.
Some of them are trying
to, I feel like, emerge
or creating new platforms,
or either buying
some of the existing
platforms, or having some kind
of interaction with them.
So the existing-- the asset
managers are definitely,
I feel like, looking
more into how
to incorporate more tools
to come to the [INAUDIBLE]
on the [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So robo advising,
the ability to have
an application on your laptop
or on your phones, of course.
Robo advising,
having an application
rather than having a
human but having analytics
embedded in a program give you
advice about asset allocation,
investing, in the like.
And then secondly, as
you said, big finance.
And big finance in this case
is asset managers, generally,
but also the brokerage
firms reacting.
What do they do?
There's one other thing
that's similar to what
we see on online
brokerage and Robinhood.
And that's about costs.
It's not just about
a delivery system.
mobile phones,
but it's also about a cost
point and a price point.
And we'll dive into
that a little bit,
but robo advisors giving access
to financial advice at lower
costs, maybe in the range of
20 to 50 basis points a year.
Asset management,
the whole field
of asset management, the
business of asset management
is accumulating assets
under management.
And if you accumulate
$100 million
of assets under management
and charge 1% fee,
that's $1 million of revenue.
If you only charge a quarter of
a point, that's only $250,000
of revenues.
Now, of course, you can multiply
because none of these firms
really want to just be
at $100 million of assets
under management.
And the biggest, BlackRocks of
the world are at $5 trillion,
$6 trillion, $7 trillion
of assets under management.
But the robo advisors
have tucked in here
at a lower cost point.
And that is also true on
the online brokerage side.
So it's delivery mechanisms.
It's user interfaces.
It's service, and it's also a
cost and, thus, price points.
In essence, can you do something
better, quicker, cheaper?
That's a very simplistic
way to think about it.
But any other FinTech trends?
There's a lot going on in
the capital markets that--
Romain, you want to see if
somebody wants-- they just
want to capture a couple of the
other trends beyond these two
on the retail side?
ROMAIN: Any volunteers?
Come on, guys.
Nikhil, go ahead.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I was muted.
I thought something
interesting was both Robinhood
and Wealthfront are moving
towards cash management.
So they enter the market
from the stock side of things
and robo advisor side
of things, but they
seem to converge to cash
management as a next product
to roll out.
So that's a big trend.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
And look, even
Betterment, which we'll
talk about in the
robo advising space,
Betterment is starting to enter
into the challenger bank area.
They're not the only ones.
You have TransferWise from
the payment side entering
into the challenger bank side.
But absolutely, some
of these platforms
are then spreading out.
So you could be robo
advisor first and then
move into something else.
Other trends, because
of data, we'll
see there's a lot of
startups, dozens of startups
in the FinTech
space around data,
around infrastructure, about
what many investors think
of as the back office side
of things that are connecting
exchanges with the public.
There are many startups
around asset management
and trying to help
asset management out.
And this would be big,
wholesale, institutional asset
management and not
just the retail side.
So let's dive into a little bit
the history of online company
landscape and think
about this for a moment.
Who really started
out this whole thing?
And I put some of
the foundation dates
and the number of customers.
These are the
figures I could get.
From time to time, I wasn't
able to online to find a figure.
But Charles Schwab
and TD Ameritrade--
you might think of
them as Ameritrade--
both started back
in the early 1970s.
Actually, free internet.
The idea was a lower
cost brokerage.
But what was happening
in the early 1970s,
a really important part of
this saga is, out of the 1960s,
there was a movement
that was ultimately
captured in congressional
action in the US.
The US Congress got involved,
the Securities and Exchange
got involved to repeal
fixed commission rates.
You see, for decades, the
New York Stock Exchange
had fixed commission rates set
by the members of the New York
Stock Exchange.
And the institutional
world, the larger investors,
wanted discounts,
wanted cheaper rates.
And in the early 1970s,
there was this movement
to free that up, not to have
fixed set rates by the New York
Stock Exchange.
And around this time,
Schwab, Ameritrade
started, later affiliated
with Toronto Dominion Bank
and thus the TD.
Each 50-some years later,
about 12 million users.
E*TRADE starts in the
'80s, Firstrade later.
Interactive Brokers,
a remarkable company,
more on the institutional side,
little less than a million
and so forth.
Monex bought
TradeStation, but Monex
from the '90s and even
TradeStation earlier.
Each of these companies were
chipping away a little bit
of the old concept of brokers.
And there were many challenges
in the 1990s into the noughts
between Schwab and Ameritrade,
and E*TRADE and traditional
firms like Merrill
Lynch and the like.
The asset managers themselves,
the big asset managers
like Fidelity and Vanguard
pre-date all of this.
But Fidelity and
Vanguard also were
saying, how can we, in
addition to wealth management,
offer online brokerage?
And as we all know,
if you have an account
with Fidelity or
Vanguard, or for that
matter with T. Rowe Price or
other large asset managers
in the US, at some point in
time in the last 20-ish years,
some starting in the mid
'90s, some waiting all the way
until the late
noughts, they started
to say they're going to
compete with traditional Wall
Street, the Merrill
Lynches and so forth.
And they were going to compete
by offering an online ability
to buy and sell stocks.
Both got into the business.
It's not that the big banks
didn't notice and everything.
And some of them, even
in the last few years,
started discount
retail packages.
Merrill Lynch, which
I keep mentioning,
Merrill Lynch Edge
2010 was a product
after Merrill Lynch was
bought by Bank of America.
And Bank of America is
thinking, OK, it's post-crisis.
They buy Merrill Lynch.
Merrill Lynch has this
remarkable multiple
1,000-person
organization of brokers,
but they do Edge to be online.
And even Ally
Bank, Ally Finance,
which started in the
auto lending business,
was that first challenger bank
in 2009, by 2016 is saying,
we can get into
this, too, online--
4 million members.
But where are we
on the startups?
The startups, Robinhood in
2013 and all this package
of startups in
the last few years
really have transformed things.
So what I was saying is
these FinTech startups,
primarily we think of
Robinhood, but there's a bunch
of others within other markets.
Like Freetrade, and
Tastyworks, and Webull
have come along partly
because of mobile phones,
partly because even the Schwabs
and Ameritrades were still
charging, whether it was
a few pennies a share,
but still charging $0.03
$0.04, $0.05 cents a share
and so forth.
User interface and cost provided
some opportunity to move in.
So I'm going to just talk a
little bit about the large
companies, that E*TRADEs,
and Ameritrades,
and Fidelities and the like for
a moment because part of it is
about mobile trading.
And they each-- and
this chart that I
was able to get from
StockBrokers.com,
a comparison was just
like, what are the apps?
What is that user interface?
And this was one example.
But better believe that whether
you're Merrill Lynch Edge
or you're Robinhood,
you're also thinking about,
do I interface well with
an iPhone, an Android,
and so forth, and Apple Watch?
I have to have that
connectivity and that technology
to be ready and used
on all of these.
And you can run
your eye through,
can I have trading on each of
these products, mutual funds?
And particularly
electronic trading
often is around ETFs
but not only ETFs.
And as the cryptocurrency space
came up, a number of them said,
well, can we trade
cryptocurrencies as well?
Not the E*TRADES
and Ameritrades,
but the Robinhoods and the
disruptors were into that
space.
So it's just a little
bit of a comparison
in how some folks think.
Recent developments
are really important.
And the biggest one
was late in 2019,
what's called the Broker Wars.
What happened start was--
at the start was Robinhood was
eating into this, 6 million,
7 million, 8 million members,
now maybe 10 million members.
And as we saw the
earlier numbers,
Schwab and Ameritrade are
only at about 12 million.
And as that was
happening, IBKR, which
is that smaller but remarkable
company, Institutional Brokers,
in September of
2019 said they were
going to go to free brokerage
for some of their accounts.
It wasn't 100%, but
they were going to go.
And within weeks,
early in October 2019,
Schwab finally said,
zero commission.
Now, what's
fascinating, I think,
is this is the
challenge that we're in.
We're in the challenge
of, are there
financial services that will
move to zero top line pricing?
And what we've
found, whether it's
in Facebook or in many, many
online applications and outside
of the financial world,
it's a zero fee environment.
And then the business model is
earning money some other way.
In Facebook's case, it's about
marketing and advertising.
90-plus% of their
revenue is really
about advertising
and marketing if you
look at that business model,
that remarkable business model.
But it may be on the data.
It may be cross-selling
and marketing.
It may be on the data.
It may be somewhere else.
We're going to talk about the
revenue model of Robinhood
in a moment.
But Charles Schwab reacted.
E*TRADE, TD Ameritrade all
within one week went to zero
commission.
And in fact, it
led to Schwab being
able to do the next
thing, which was announce
the purchase of Ameritrade.
With collapsing
revenues in Ameritrade,
Schwab could
actually say, we're--
they made him an offer,
purchase for $26 billion.
Morgan Stanley wasn't
going to be outdone.
And early in 2020,
Morgan Stanley,
one of the most venerable
old-line investment banks
dating all the way
back to James--
to J.P. Morgan himself, the
industrialist that though
he's departed this world
many decades ago has his name
on Morgan Stanley
and JP Morgan Chase,
Morgan Stanley buys
E*TRADE earlier this year.
If you would have told the
Morgan Stanley executives when
E*TRADE started 30 years ago
that some time they would
in their future buy E*TRADE,
they would have scratched
their head and said, really?
We're going to be a retail
online brokerage firm?
So it's an interesting
change in this world.
So what's the long road?
What's the long
road of commissions?
This is the-- a
much earlier chart,
but if you look
at this gray line,
this commission rates
from $0.25 a share
down to about $0.03 cents
a share in 2008 or 2009.
I think this chart
cuts off around 2008.
This long march of
competition in part
is because of volumes
as you can see on this,
that volumes were going up and
commissions were going down.
So some of it is
just efficiency,
but it's also this competition
that was coming in from E*TRADE
and Ameritrade on
the retail side.
But Robinhood
entered a world that
still had $0.03, $0.04,
$0.05 cents commission.
Robinhood initially
did an online app
that was easy with a mobile
phone to start an account.
But what they also did is they
said, we'll do it for free.
Their business model from
2013 on, we'll do it for free.
And how did they do that?
What's the revenue
model behind that?
Anybody want to take a
moment of pause, Romain?
I will answer this question.
I'm just saying, Romain,
who amongst the class
would think, how
could you be so bold?
As a startup venture
capitalist, you
start an entrepreneurial
effort free online brokerage
from day one.
ROMAIN: Any volunteers?
Victor.
AUDIENCE: I guess you can either
make a profit on lending money
to traders so they
can purchase stock.
And you can also use some
high-frequency trading,
as some people said, that's
probably what it's doing
in order to before you sell,
you actually go through a--
determine the area to
make a profit out of.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So Victor's raised two things.
I'm going to focus
on the second,
was the relationship of
these mobile platforms,
Robinhood in particularly,
and high-frequency trading.
What Robinhood knew was that a
feature of the capital markets
was that there were firms
that would pay for order flow.
They would pay a very modest
amount, maybe a penny a share,
but they would pay just
to receive the order flow.
And this is a feature of
the competitive markets,
the competitive
exchange markets.
In the US, we have 50 to
70 individual exchanges.
We think of the New
York Stock Exchange.
We think about
NASDAQ and so forth,
but there are many
other electronic markets
where transactions occur.
And some people call
them the dark markets.
But all of those markets
might pay for order flow.
And then individual
trading shops,
high-frequency trading shops,
might pay for order flow.
What that means is they
want to have a first look.
They want to have those
orders and to route them
through their algorithms and
into their either exchange
engines, if it's an exchange
that's paying for order flow,
or a high-frequency trading shop
that's paying for order flow.
And the exchanges have
different fee structures
depending upon whether
you make a bid or offer
or you take a bid or offer.
You will sometimes hear this
called maker and taker rates.
Making a bid or offer, putting
a resting bid or a resting offer
into an exchange engine is
more valuable for the exchange
because it brings other
orders into the exchange.
So what Robinhood
figured out was
they could offer the retail
public something for free
because they entered into
two or three major contracts
with hedge funds, with
high-frequency trading
shops saying, we will
enter into something
where we're selling you the
order flow for a modest amount.
I don't know the exact
amount, but let's
call it a penny a share inside
the pricing of the $0.03
or so to $0.05 that the
online brokers were charging,
but still very valuable
over time for Robinhood.
And then bingo, 6 or 8
million members later,
account holders later
and a good user face,
we get into the Broker Wars
where others drop their rates
as well.
And so then I go to this
interesting zero commission
model chart that
talks about, well,
how could you have the cost
of financial advice be zero?
Well, it's because
of everything else.
And the everything else model,
whether it's for Morgan Stanley
and E*TRADE, whether it's
for Schwab, Charles Schwab,
or whether it's for
Robinhood, as Victor said,
this is everything else that
might be valuable for you.
Picking up payment
for order flow
is the third one on this
list, but margin interest,
maintenance fees,
transaction fees,
saying once you have a client,
there's a lot of other revenues
that can be garnered.
So once Facebook has
your information,
there are other revenues
that Facebook can garner.
But in the brokerage space,
this is very well known.
This was known in the 1960s and
1970s when the large investment
banks would think, if
I have a relationship
with this big insurance company,
I can earn money in other ways.
It's what led in part
in the early 1970s
to break the old
decades-old fixed commission
rates because large
investment banks wanted
to discount and lower their
rates for large institutions,
not for the retail public
but for large institutions.
That was 50 years
ago, but that was also
because there's all
this revenue potential,
as this little graphic
says, beneath the surface.
Romain, questions if I can
pause a little bit, because it's
about the business
models of brokerage
and the business models
of investment banking.
ROMAIN: Let's wait a few
seconds so people have the time.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE] lived
at Goldman Sachs for 18 years,
even though that feels
like another era.
ROMAIN: So we have
a few questions.
Let's take Luke and then Hassan.
AUDIENCE: So I have
one quick question
when it comes to traders
or trading platforms.
Banks usually make money by
holding deposits in daily basis
because that's a
revenue to the firm.
It's especially
hard to do so in US
when interest rate is near zero.
But in emerging markets, such
as Korea, China, or India,
they basically make the revenue
if you have somebody's money.
And you can lend it out in a
net interest margin of positive.
How do platforms like
these, E*TRADE or Robinhood,
make money when they transfer
the money from deposit
to their account and
takes two, three days,
and they can make money out
of it besides these hedge fund
deals that you have explained?
GARY GENSLER: So
a great question.
So the classic what I would
call commercial bank model
is exactly what Luke said.
To pot-- there's a net interest
spread between the depositors'
money and what you lended out.
And whether you're a $1 trillion
bank or a $100 million bank,
it's basically that spread
between the depositors' money
and what you're lending out.
That model has been
around for centuries.
And as Luke said,
it's a little bit more
challenging in different
interest rate environments,
but that's been there.
The brokerage
business traditionally
was making money on
commissions, and commissions
was a big part of that
revenue model all the way
through the 1960s and '70s.
But there's other
pieces of it as well
beyond just the
commission of, as we
saw on that chart, $0.25
a share long ago or $0.03
or $0.05 a share more recently.
Beyond that, it's also, when
you buy and sell securities,
you-- there is what's known
as a bid-offer spread,
the difference
between the bid side
and where somebody is offering.
And a market maker
can be in the middle
and provide liquidity
to the market,
get paid for taking risks.
It's a risk-return business.
But first, Luke, is
the bid-offer spread,
just being in the flow.
In Robinhood's case,
Robinhood said,
we don't have a balance sheet.
We're not going to pay
for the bid-ask spread.
But we will enter
into transactions
with high-frequency
trading shops
and effectively give them access
to this flow of transactions.
And so that's payment
for order flow.
And the high-frequency
trading shops
are, in essence, trying to tap
into that bid-offer spread.
So that's a dominant part of it.
In addition, just to
name one other, but there
are many others--
in addition, Charles
Schwab and others--
Merrill Lynch figured
this out decades ago.
Once you have that
customer relationship,
that customer relationship will
come to you for other things,
and they will come to you
to do margin lending, which
is a form of borrowing.
And so you have maybe
then that customer there
who you can actually
use your balance sheet
and lend them money, usually
what's called margin lending.
So I'm just mentioning
two of them.
Bid-ask spread, Robinhood was
not taking that themselves.
They were selling that access.
And then the
relationship that you
can have when using your
balance sheet and lending money.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell us a
little bit about the kickbacks
in the presentation?
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us a little bit
about the kickbacks in
the presentation you
have here in the small letters?
GARY GENSLER: Well,
these are not my words.
These are Jason
Wenk of Altruist.
But in essence, there's
so many different ways
that you might take a
customer's order flow
and sell access to that, or you
might be the front end model.
You could be-- I'm not saying
Robinhood or Schwab are
doing this, but you can
be that front end model.
And then somebody else will
pay you, pay the Schwab,
pay the Robinhood.
And so I think what Jason
Wenk, who wrote this,
is calling that a kickback.
But it's a contractual
arrangement
to be-- have access to that
customer and that order flow.
AUDIENCE: Can I safely assume
that they're selling our data
as well as Google is doing?
GARY GENSLER: So data
is really important,
and data is really important
for multiple reasons.
One, the better data you
have, the better trading
algorithms you can create.
So part of the
payment for order flow
is to capture bid-ask spread.
Part of the payment
for order flow
is the data so that you
can build your algorithms.
You have more data for your
machine learning, absolutely.
There's also other
relevant data,
but fundamentally the data
is to be a better market
maker and a better investor.
I think Romain, there was
somebody else that still
had a question before I go on.
ROMAIN: Yes, Hassan.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Professor.
Yeah.
My question is about
the bid-ask margin.
And I'm just wondering,
I mean, so for instance
like Robinhood, they--
so because they
had many customers,
they could get better
deals, and they
could benefit from the flow
of customers that they have.
Is this how they make money?
I'm just wondering.
GARY GENSLER: Well, so actually,
the way they made money is they
were getting paid for that flow
because their business model
early on, and others
like them now,
said we will go to the investing
public and zero commission.
And somebody else will pay us.
A fraction of a penny
at this point in time
would be enough, but
a fraction of a penny.
That other party
would pay us to,
in essence, route those
transactions to the stock
exchanges.
And so one company that
does pay for order flow
is a large hedge fund
high-frequency shop
from Chicago called
Citadel, which
I don't know its
current size, but it
used to be about a $20 billion
hedge fund asset management
shop and very active in
high-frequency trading.
It's very public that it is.
And so Citadel is one of those
vendors on the other side
of the Robinhood app.
And then they find a way, as
we were talking with Luke.
They find the Citadels of
the world, not just Citadel.
They find that order flow
is then valuable for them.
They're routing some of
it to the Stock Exchange,
and that could still
be worth something.
They're putting it
into their analytics.
They then get better
sophisticated machine
learning on the analytics.
And that order flow
is also something
that can be very valuable to an
operator of a dark market, one
of these small
electronic markets,
because you're all competing.
If there's 60 or 70 of
these small dark markets,
they're all competing for
volume and market share.
And then all of the
sudden, Robinhood has not
just a few 100,000 customers,
but they have 5 million or 10
million customers.
Then they can provide
a lot of order flow
and a lot of market coverage
for somebody on the other side.
Now, as it relates to Schwab,
Schwab and some of the earlier
online brokers, they got into
the business of collecting
assets under management.
They got into the asset under
management custodial side
of the business as well.
There's a lot of other revenue
streams, transaction fees,
account maintenance fees,
and even advisory fees
in those shops.
I want to move on now
to wealth management.
I think you'll see
merging between the wealth
management fees and
the brokerage fees,
which is exactly what
we've seen over time
in the traditional
brokerage field.
In the traditional
brokerage field for decades,
a broker earned commissions.
And then they started
by the late 1990s,
with some support
from the regulators,
to change their revenue models.
The traditional
Merrill Lynch broker
from the 1930s to the 1980s
was a commission-based broker.
But by the 1990s, they started
to charge advisory fees,
meaning for instance,
maybe 1% of the assets
that you left with them.
And if you leave $1 million,
if you're wealthy enough
to have that $1
million, that means
that they're earning $10,000
a year on your account.
If you obviously had
more, that would even
be better for Merrill
Lynch and worse for you
because you'd be leaving
them a lot of money to just
be a custodian for
your account largely
and to give you advice
from time to time.
And that's the set up
for the next discussion.
Romain, any questions?
ROMAIN: No.
All good.
GARY GENSLER: So robo
advisory-- and Hassan sort of
helped me set this up.
I'm going to do the
same sort of landscape.
We have the same groups,
retail brokers, asset managers,
and the banks.
Advisory work, brokerage
advisory was largely,
for many decades, the
domain of investment banks
and broker dealers, Merrill
Lynch, Smith Barney,
Paine Webber, many, many
companies across the land,
small and large.
And they were a
commission-based business.
By the 1990s, as
I mentioned, they
started to move to a financial
advisory commission number.
And I can't remember exactly
what year it was in the 1990s.
Even the Securities
and Exchange Commission
changed some rules to
facilitate some of that.
Coming from the other side,
the big asset managers
managing pension money and
managing big pools of money
through mutual
funds also started
to get into the
retail advisory space.
And thirdly, you
had the brokers,
the Schwabs and so forth.
Now, I've put some names here
like Charles Schwab Intelligent
Portfolios, which is a more
recent rollout, that branding,
Intelligent Portfolios
or TD America's
Ameritrade's
Essential Portfolios,
more recent roll out for them.
And they've been
reacting to this crowd,
this remarkable,
entrepreneurial, mobile app
robo advisors.
And these companies span the
globe in Europe, US, and Asia.
But what Betterment, or
Nutmeg, and others are doing
is they're saying, we can
give more financial inclusion,
and we can do it in a better
user interface and a lower cost
structure.
By and large, the
asset management fees
for an account in the
traditional brokerage
environment was
hovering close to 1%.
There was some
price compression.
Some of it was coming down
into the 3/4 of 1% to 1% area.
That means, again, if you were
fortunate enough to have--
let's just say that
you had $500,000,
and you were able to have
somebody invest it for you
or advise you.
1% of $500,000 is $5,000.
That's $400 a month that
you were paying, in essence,
for somebody to give
you occasional advice
and be your custodian for
your electronic securities,
because everything was
digital by this point in time.
It was no longer those
earlier days where
you had physical certificates.
This group came
along and said, maybe
we could do it at a different
price point, a better user
interface, maybe better
analytics and service,
generally somewhere between 30
to 50 basis points or a quarter
to a half a percent.
That same $500,000, if you
were to have that $500,000,
all of the sudden doesn't cost
you $5,000 or $4,000 a year,
but it's costing maybe $1,500
a year or $100 a month.
Now, you don't get a bill
for the $100 a month.
It just comes out each
month out of your account,
and it's charged
as a fee per se.
But there's generally a
different price point.
We haven't gone all the way that
we went with online brokerage,
to mobile brokerage, to
zero accounts, zero fees.
But one of the great pressures
that have happened here
as well, which is off this
page, is asset management fees
have been coming down
as well and particularly
around a product called
exchange traded funds.
And to understand the
field of robo advisors,
I just want to mention
something about exchange traded
funds, which is an
invention of the late 1990s.
That was a FinTech of its
time that somebody came up
with the idea, I can
have a mutual fund.
I can have a mutual fund that
invests in the entire market,
and I can do it at a low cost.
And I can package it
through a security.
So let me unpack that.
The first innovation was an
innovation of the early 1970s.
Jack Bogle, who was the key
innovator behind Vanguard,
said, wouldn't it be great if
we gave America at the time
a product they can invest
in the whole stock market
a little bit of each company?
And we're not going
to manage it for them.
We're just going to
algorithmically, arithmetically
pick a little bit
of every stock.
And it was called an index fund.
We take it for
granted, but that was
an innovation, a remarkable
innovation of the 1970s.
Everybody could have a piece of
the stock market at a low cost.
And to this day, Vanguard is
still not a publicly traded
for-profit company.
It's a mutual company.
Vanguard is held and
owned by its mutual funds
that are held and owned by us
if we're a part of Vanguard.
That innovation then
led to an innovation
in the 1990s that
said, what can we
do to make this
even more efficient?
What if we take an
index mutual fund
and take the interest
in the mutual funds
and make those securities?
Took a little change
in some regulations,
but all of the sudden, we had
this thing called exchange
traded funds, these
low-cost ways to participate
in the stock market,
the bond market,
some in the gold
and silver markets--
exchange traded funds.
All of these robo advisors
in their packaging have said,
we can get you into
this and get you out
of this, into this market
or out of this market,
and use exchange traded funds.
The second big innovation
for robo advisors, of course,
is everything we talked about
out of artificial intelligence
and natural language
programming, processing,
the ability to take voice or
take digital and transfer that
into machine language, computer
language, and the reverse.
So robo advisors came
along at a point in time
where you could basically
automate us humans a bit,
not entirely, but
we could step back.
Humans step back, and
robo advice goes in.
And you could do it
a lower price point.
And the third
innovation was basically
some simple analytics--
not machine learning, but
simple analytics on portfolio
and asset allocation.
Some of it's related to,
if you're in your 20s
and you're saving
for retirement,
you could take more risk.
You could have a higher equity
share versus a bond share.
If you're in your 60s, and
you're about to retire,
you should be more stable,
a little less risk, maybe
more bonds and less equities.
Some of it's that
simple, but they were
able to basically take that.
And so the Betterment
started, and they
could find really readily
available software
for asset allocation.
They could use products
like exchange traded funds.
Mobile phones were
around already.
So they had a good platform.
And they say, all right,
we'll go to a lower fee point.
And all of the sudden, we start
to see a real change of things.
Questions, Romain?
ROMAIN: While we wait for
questions on this topic,
we have a question in the chat
about Robinhood's business
model from George.
Do you see Robinhood
and other startups
starting their own
high-frequency trading
operations instead of
selling the order flows?
And then Devin asks
whether maybe Citadel
or any other hedge fund should
just buy Robinhood outright.
GARY GENSLER: These are
two really great questions
about the future.
I think that in both ways
will the front end platform--
and that's really, in a sense,
Robinhood and, even in this
robo advisor space, the
Betterments of the world--
is a front end user
interface platform
that tend not to
have balance sheets.
And they tend to let somebody
else handle that capital
markets risk behind it.
But the question here is,
do I see the front end
building balance sheet and
moving into the capital market
side?
And do I see the capital
market side, the balance sheet
risk taking, moving
into the front end side?
And we don't know,
but history tells
us that tends to
happen at some point,
that there's some
sort of what you might
call vertical integration.
And if you really think about
these slices on this page,
the JP Morgan building you
invest in 2018 or Merrill Edge
in an earlier time--
and if I go back to
the brokerage side,
they're named
products there, too--
that's balance sheet
coupled with front end.
That's the fully
integrated model.
But then if you look at the
asset managers, the asset
managers, the
BlackRocks of the world
are not actually
acting as a principal.
They're acting as an advisor,
a pure advisor, a pure agency
business.
So one of the things is, do you
just want to stay as an agent,
or do you actually
want to invest
your capital in the markets?
And that big business
decision separates
some of the asset managers
and then, as you mentioned,
the high-frequency traders.
I think that if Robinhood
is going to be bought,
it could be bought by
high-frequency trading shop.
But the challenge
there is, will they
still get as big
a customer base,
I mean 10 million customers?
Or is Robinhood more valuable
for one of the large banks
to buy or one of the
large asset managers?
I think if you look out
three to five years,
it's quite likely that Robinhood
gets merged up into something,
as you saw Morgan Stanley
buying E*TRADE as well.
Another question?
ROMAIN: Yes.
Let's go with Camillo.
GARY GENSLER: And then I'm going
to do a few more slides here
on robo advisors.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Gary.
I wonder why platforms such
as Acorns and Betterment
that you were just talking about
have a mixed business model,
because in one way, they are
a robo advisor business model.
But then they have savings
and checking accounts.
GARY GENSLER: Correct.
AUDIENCE: They're stepping
a foot into a banking model.
What's the reason to merge
the two spaces into one?
GARY GENSLER: I think because
they have the front end
customer relationship,
and they have some trust.
And this helps set something up.
This is a chart on users.
And it's got some
predictions here.
We don't know if these
predictions will hold.
But if you see the
use of robo advisors,
it's just getting
much more comfortable
that folks are being--
and this, I believe,
also includes the robo
advisors at the big shops
as well as the startups.
But just as if you have
that user interface--
and remember we talked
about challenger banks
as well, Camillo,
the challenger banks
last session, a lot of
it's about trust as well.
Once you have that
user interface,
there's a certain trust and,
frankly, stickiness to it.
So if Betterment, which is
looking to become a challenger
bank, can use that
customer relationship,
then you can build the platform.
And back to the
economics of platforms,
the economics of platforms
is as you layer activities
on top of a platform, and if
you can grow your user base,
you get more data, you
get more centrality.
There's not going to
be 10 years from now
this many advisory platforms.
And in fact, in the blue,
the advisory platforms,
I picked the ones
that are large.
There's 50 to 100 others
that I haven't listed.
So there is going
to be consolidation.
As sure as we're
here at this moment,
there's going to be
consolidation in this space.
And so they're trying to build
classic platform economics,
build activities,
build user bases.
And this is assets
under management,
the same website behind this.
But as of a few days ago, just
a sense of, what are the assets?
This is in billions.
So in 2020, $1.2 trillion
of assets under management
somehow associated
with robo advisors.
So even a 1/4%
fee on this starts
to be a real revenue model.
Possible evolution, I
like thinking about,
where could this
go in the future?
Where did robo advising start,
all the way on the left?
It's just an online
questionnaire
about asset allocation largely,
and an online questionnaire,
a mobile questionnaire about
products and risk and how--
and then usually
a list of exchange
traded funds, some bonds.
So simple but very accessible,
broadening financial inclusion
for lower rates.
And it helps a lot of
people, a lot of investors
sleep well at night.
It lowers their uncertainty.
I'm getting some good advice
about asset allocation,
some risks, some life events.
But could move it move further?
That's the question.
Can it move further?
And exactly like Camillo said
and Luke's earlier question
about other revenues, can robo
advisors-- like Betterment
say, well, we'll actually
be the fund manager.
We'll start to actually
manage the funds
rather than just doing
these low-cost ETFs.
And maybe we'll
start to actually do
something more
with regard to risk
based portfolio allocation.
Maybe we'll start in
this third column,
do a little bit of algorithms.
Maybe, in fact, we'll
start to do trading and be
principals rather than just
an agent and an advisor
and the like.
So there's going to be more
sophisticated algorithmic AI
or machine learning.
But I don't think it's going to
be highly sophisticated machine
learning because there's
a certain commoditization
about the advice.
But it is quite possible
as we move forward
that somebody will figure
out what risk I should
take versus somebody else.
Andrew Lo, a faculty
member at MIT,
thinks that you can
take machine learning
and embed it in even an
index fund, that you could
have inside of an index fund--
what Andy talks about is
called "the freakout factor,"
that we all have
different risk profiles.
When the stock market
goes out, down,
how likely are we to, quote, as
he says, "freak out" and want
to sell?
And that we could, based upon
other aspects of our lives,
put that into a
machine learning model
and have it automatically
adjust up and down.
Questions before I think
I'm going to go to the--
broadly the capital
markets piece?
ROMAIN: We have a question.
GARY GENSLER: So we've
sort of covered--
I'm pausing here for a
second, but we've sort of
covered the online
brokerage, robo advisor,
those two big pieces as captured
by Robinhood and Betterment,
might be the two companies
that are the leads of the pack,
but they're not alone.
And in the wealth
management side,
it's much more evenly split,
whereas in the mobile side,
in the mobile brokerage
side, Robinhood
seemed to really sort of
punched high and done well.
ROMAIN: The only
question we have here
is from the chat from Luke.
What kind of US
regulation is [INAUDIBLE]
the likes of Robinhood
to expand globally
or to attract
capital from abroad?
GARY GENSLER: Well, this
is a highly regulated
space in both the advisory
side and the brokerage side.
And Robinhood would certainly
need to be aware of that
and register appropriately as
a broker dealer here in the US.
And then on the asset
management side,
there's a little bit different
regulation but also regulated
here.
Attracting capital
from overseas,
if the capital is just
investing in Robinhood,
in one of their venture
rounds, BCD rounds,
because these are probably
private placements largely
speaking, other than
the usual regulations
around sanctions and
anti-money laundering,
it'd be straightforward.
If it's actually customers
using the platform,
then a Robinhood would have
to be aware of the regulations
in that jurisdiction, whether
it's the regulations in Europe
or in your home country,
Luke,-- in Korea, that they'd--
those customer-facing
applications, Robinhood Korea
would have to think, do they
register as a broker dealer
in Korea or Japan and the
like, as they are, in fact,
just a mobile application
for a traditional investment
brokerage firm?
So again trying to
capture capital markets.
Capital markets is a
vast array of activities
from accessing capital to
trading platforms and the like.
And this slide
from McKinsey just
captures an earlier
stage of, where
is FinTech in each of these?
And I'm not going to go
through each of these buckets,
but part of why I have this is
it's so many little buckets.
We talked about two
on the retail side.
There are crowdfunding
platforms, literally platforms
that help companies raise money.
There's trade execution, and
I'm going to talk about a couple
in a minute,
decentralized trading
platforms like cryptocurrencies,
but also centralized trading
platforms and cryptocurrencies.
But even in the last
few years, a firm
called IEX is a startup
in trade execution.
It's a new trading platform.
There's post-trade services.
There's a lot of
infrastructure and operations.
The capital markets are a vast
multi-trillion dollar business
globally in terms of revenues.
So I'm just going to
quickly touch upon some
in these next couple of slides.
You can see, I picked
some dozen or so firms
that were just ones I kind
of like to watch and follow.
We can take any questions
about each of these,
but there are a number of them
in the wealth management space.
And one of the things in wealth
management we talked about,
like Betterment, is
facing the retail public.
But there are startups that are
in the wealth management space
facing financial advisors.
These tens of thousands
of financial advisors
want better software.
And Addepar and a
number of others
are actually platforms for
the financial advisors,
that financial advisor that's
trying to build a business
wants software and access
to the capital market.
So it's an interface
between the two.
There's a bunch that are in the
area of collateral management
and infrastructure, CloudMargin.
Literally, collateral
management means the collateral
that you're moving
on derivatives
in the institutional
market or collateral
that you're moving even
as it relates to loans.
And why not start
a platform that
might be a little better
for collateral management
and take some of the back
office cost out of it?
And not to be outdone,
you could have
digital fixed-income brokers
as well as equity brokers.
What we were talking about
earlier was the stock market
and this company
called Elephant.
I mentioned IEX started in 2012.
It's to be a competitive
stock market to NASDAQ,
New York Stock Exchange
started by a bunch of buy side
institutions, for instance.
And sometimes,
it's just research.
PitchBook and others
like PitchBook
put together a
remarkable data base
on the financial business of
venture capital, for instance.
So it could be a lot
of different spaces.
Back to thinking about the
different aspects of capital
markets, crowdfunding
platforms, trade execution,
the post-trade side of it.
I don't do this to be like a
full course on capital markets,
but it's to open your
thinking to it's not just
the retail interface.
It's not just using a mobile
phone, good data, good user
delivery, and lower cost.
And that's really the
Robinhood, Betterment side.
It's also a lot of taking
the paper flows out
of it, old processes
out of the back office,
and trying to provide a
service to the capital
markets in a better way.
Romain, any--
ROMAIN: Any hands raised?
Anyone has a question
on this topic?
No.
I think we can move on.
GARY GENSLER: Let me just
close out crypto markets a bit.
And some of you take the
crypto finance course,
so it may be a little
bit repetitive.
But let me just say, one
thing that's interesting
is this crypto
market came along.
Is there a question here?
ROMAIN: Luke has
his hand raised.
GARY GENSLER: Let me hold Luke
because he's had a lot here.
So let me just say
something on crypto markets,
and then we'll definitely
take Luke's question.
But the crypto markets came
along about a dozen years ago.
And by an early stage of these
markets, somebody said, how
can you buy and sell Bitcoin?
And they created exchanges,
a new form of exchange,
not for equities,
not for bonds, not
for foreign currencies
or Fiat currencies,
but cryptocurrencies.
And these exchanges act
as agents matching buyers
and sellers like
traditional exchanges,
but they also act
as market makers.
We talked earlier about
capturing bid-ask spread.
These exchanges could also
buy and sell from customers.
Not all of them
do, but they could.
Traditional exchanges did not.
And they also acted as a
custody and held your funds.
And even to this day, if you
trade on a crypto exchange,
you're moving your
asset through the use
of what's called a private key.
But you're moving your asset
to the crypto exchange,
and they're the custody.
They're the custodian.
The public has direct access.
And this is a very
different model
than traditional exchanges.
And the question
will be, will this
come to traditional markets?
And that's why I wanted
to focus on this minute.
In traditional markets built
upon a business model that's
multiple centuries
old, you and I
are not members directly of
the New York Stock Exchange.
We have to go through somebody
to get to the New York Stock
Exchange.
That's called a broker.
It's called a member of the
New York Stock Exchange,
or the London Stock Exchange,
or the Shanghai Stock Exchange.
But in these markets,
in these crypto markets
everybody can access
directly the markets.
The markets actually,
interestingly,
have to have a much more robust
API for the retail public.
The New York Stock Exchange
and London Stock Exchange
have to have a robust API,
application program interface,
for institutions.
And it has to be very high
volume, very resilient.
But it can be
limited to hundreds
or, at most, a couple
thousands of users
even if the volumes are high.
These exchanges have to be
open to millions of people
from their home laptops
and mobile phones--
a very different architecture
where it's disintermediated
the broker dealers.
And the question I have, which
is unanswerable right now,
will this be something
moving forward?
Will we see a
direct access model
at any exchange
around the globe,
or will we stay in the
intermediated access?
There's a lot of
regulatory reasons
we'd stay in the
intermediated access.
There's some competitive
reasons brokers wouldn't want
to have folks going directly.
But on the other
hand, the technology
now exists that you
could go directly.
And so these markets, by the
way, are not well regulated.
And they're rife with fraud,
and scams, and manipulation.
So I just want to mention that.
I see a few hands in
addition to Luke's hand.
So maybe we should pause.
ROMAIN: Yes, Carlos?
GARY GENSLER: And we
have to get Luke's, too.
But, Carlos, all right.
AUDIENCE: So what do
you think would happen
if the big banks started holding
more crypto on their balance
sheets, right?
If they start acting as market
makers in crypto markets,
then would it-- for example,
under current regulation,
would this asset go
under Dodd-Frank as well
and therefore limit
proprietary trading,
or do you think it
would be different?
GARY GENSLER: So there's a
lot of questions in there.
The large banks
around the globe today
have not been active
in this asset class.
The asset class is
about $225 billion
as of this morning,
which is small.
The worldwide capital markets
are between $300 trillion
and $400 trillion when you add
equities and bonds worldwide
and debt.
So this is quite
small in comparison.
But for regulatory reasons and
for customer interest reasons,
the large banks
haven't really gone in.
If they were to get in, to
answer answer your question
on the regulatory
side, yes, it would
be just like any other asset
they have, any commodity.
So if you hold
Bitcoin, you might
think if you're JP Morgan,
I'm now holding it.
I'm Barclays bank.
What regulations?
If it's Bitcoin, it would be
very similar to the regulations
around holding gold or silver.
Maybe you would hold gold or
silver futures or contracts,
but holding gold, silver.
And to the extent
that there was a--
you mentioned Dodd-Frank.
If there were any rules and
regulations out of Dodd-Frank
that were generally applicable
to trading accounts,
it would be applicable to
these trading accounts.
The one big challenge for
big institutions is custody.
Custody has been a challenge.
And what's interesting is
Fidelity, one of the largest
asset managers in
the world, started
something called Fidelity
Digital Asset holding--
I believe that's the name--
where they are providing
a custody solution.
Coinbase, which is a
large crypto exchange,
has a custody solution.
The owner of the New York
Stock Exchange Intercontinental
Exchange started
Bakkt, B-A-K-K-T.
Bakkt is trading crypto markets
but also providing a custody
solution.
And why I'm focusing
on custody is
one of the challenges in
this small asset class is
how to hold the digital asset.
In the traditional
markets, there
are centralized
organizations that
operate as
clearinghouses but also
as the ultimate
digital custodian.
In the US, it's called DTCC.
And other countries
have different names.
But how do you make sure that,
in essence, the cryptocurrency
isn't stolen?
These crypto exchanges have had
lots of stolen cryptocurrency
because once you
steal what's called
the private key,
effectively the password,
you have the digital asset.
What was Luke's
question earlier?
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of cryptocurrency,
I know you teach in H4, the
cryptocurrency class, which
I don't have the
luxury of taking
but [INAUDIBLE]
have the opportunity
to take next semester
or next year.
My question is then, is
that because of the security
that Robinhood does
not implement customers
the option to buy US
equity with Bitcoin
overseas, because
they would allow
them to jump over its
respective nations
ethics regulations, i.e.
Chinese customers
or Korean customers
who want to invest in ONG--
GARY GENSLER: I--
AUDIENCE: --buy low,
sell high with Bitcoin?
GARY GENSLER: Yes, Luke.
I'm going to answer briefly.
I think the regulation for any
one platform like Robinhood
around cryptocurrencies
is a bit challenging
because in many
jurisdictions, we have not
gotten to a place
where you can feel
confident we have a
robust investor protection
regime on cryptocurrency.
And in fact, in
most jurisdictions,
it's pretty shaky.
It's pretty still undeveloped.
I'm talking about
investor protection.
So Robinhood may
have made a choice,
look, if you're going
to trade, you're
going to trade Fiat currency
versus buying and selling
stocks.
And that would be an
appropriate business decision
that they made until
there is a much more
robust and satisfactory
both investor protection
and also guarding
against illicit activity.
Cryptocurrency started
and emanated out
of a little bit of an off
the grid cypherpunk movement.
And I use the word accurately.
Cypherpunk was a mailing
list that Satoshi Nakamoto
uploaded that eight-page
paper on 12 years ago.
And though you can track
Bitcoin transactions,
a lot of use of Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies
has been to avoid the
censorship and the watchful eyes
of the official sector.
And so I would imagine--
I've not talked to
Robinhood-- that they
would be aware of that.
And they would just feel
as both a legal matter
and for reputational
reasons, better not
to go there unless
there is a more
robust support for that system.
ROMAIN: And Nadia had
her hand up for a while.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE]
ROMAIN: Nadia?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I actually have two questions
on wealth management FinTech.
So the first
question, what do you
think more important for wealth
management FinTech to grow?
Is it the inclusion
part, meaning
like low minimum deposit,
or the user experience part?
That is for the first questions.
And for the second
question, given the growth
of past management
feature like Wealthfront,
do you think now customers
prefer a simpler product rather
than more complicated product?
GARY GENSLER: So there's
a lot there, Nadia.
I'm not sure what--
but I think that the Betterments
and the robo advisors,
I can't separate the two.
When you're saying, is it
more about user interface,
is it more about pricing, maybe
somebody better than I could,
but I think it's about both.
I really do think that.
I think that they have provided
a lower price point, which
is really important.
But if it were only that,
if somebody had just
put out an advertisement,
I'm going to give you
wealth advice for a
quarter of a point,
I don't think you could
have gotten adoption.
I think you had to have
that user interface.
And I think the two of them
together are really important.
So it's not just doing
something cheaper,
because a lot of people
could say, listen,
I'll give you wealth advice
for a quarter of a point.
I think the user experience--
these are very private matters.
Sometimes it's just
frankly a little easier.
It's interesting to just
go to a drop down menu,
answer some questions, feel
that I'm getting the advice,
feel that I'm, yes,
getting low-cost ETFs
and low-cost advisory fees.
But I think the user
experience goes hand in hand.
And I can't easily
separate them.
Let me just try to wrap up.
And then, Nadia, remind me the
second half of your question
as I wrap up, because I
want to make a-- we only
have about 3 minutes.
So I want to just make a point
beyond these crypto exchanges.
There's a bunch of crypto
lending and borrowing.
And why I raise this
is this market, just
like the capital markets,
is starting to say,
can I lend to crypto?
Can I borrow crypto?
And why would you do that?
Same reason in the
capital markets.
You lend and borrow
stock sometimes
because you want to buy
the stocks on margin.
Or sometimes you
lend it because you
need to borrow against your
assets to do something else.
So these markets are
developing that way,
but the thing that
I wanted to mention
was this question of
decentralized finance
versus centralized finance.
Centralized
traditional finance--
this is a slide that I created
in the last eight months--
has proprietary software,
central clearing,
all the attributes
that I list here.
The question is, is there
a market just like we
talked about in lending for peer
to peer decentralized finance?
And what we found in
LendingClub and other companies,
they really haven't
stayed decentralized.
They started with this
concept that we'll
be peers lending to peers.
And then what we found is
they've become more marketplace
platforms.
And platform economics
have taken over.
But there's been this
question, can there
be an open source software built
on blockchain technology that's
truly peer to peer?
And you will hear
this time and again.
It's a business
concept that I just
want to prepare you for,
decentralized finance
versus traditional
finance, usually used
in the context of
blockchain technology.
And the advocates say blockchain
technology facilitates--
we can get rid of the big banks.
That is what they might say.
That's what Satoshi
Nakamoto wrote
in some of the early emails
and so forth, that we
can disintermediate both
banks and central banks
around cryptocurrency
and the like.
That's the dream.
But the question is
whether network economics--
whether there's a reason in
capital markets and finance
that you have a hub and
spoke approach rather
than a decentralized approach.
When I say "hub and spoke,"
the New York Stock Exchange
or London Stock Exchange is
in the middle of the market,
that the banks, back to
Luke's earlier question,
are sitting there collecting
a net interest margin
and why LendingClub is moved
into a marketplace platform
rather than that peer to peer.
And so this debate and
this business concept
is a relatively important one,
and it basically goes well
beyond cryptocurrencies.
And I wanted to mention it.
But in cryptocurrencies-- and
this is my last little bit--
is that there are
DeFi platforms,
decentralized finance
where you can peer to peer
use a crypto exchange.
Binance, IDEX, Uniswap,
others basically say,
we're not going to have a
central exchange or, more
technically, a central
limit order book.
But Nadia and I could trade.
And later Nadia could
trade with Luke,
and Camillo could trade
with somebody else,
but it's not all centralized.
And similarly,
there's platforms--
Maker DAO, and
Compound, and Synthetix
are the three big ones--
that are trying to do that on
crypto lending and borrowing.
There is even prediction
marking markets
that are trying to say Nadia can
trade with Luke and make a bet.
Now, the regulatory environment
for these prediction markets
is highly challenged,
and they might
be doing things that are
not strictly within the law.
But these decentralized
markets are very small.
None of these projects
are really big.
But some of these projects
have a few billion
dollars in their
crypto lending and.
Borrowing some of
these exchanges
have a few hundred thousand
dollars a day of trading.
They're not big.
But back-- it raises
this central question
of traditional finance
versus decentralized finance.
And I just wanted to capture
that before we signed off
today.